so what we're designating the season
zero battle pass um
and and sort of what that's going to be
for players in this technical preview
yeah so when you when we take a look at
ourselves learning as a team
reason why we want to do season zero is
like the rest of our live experience
our team needs to build the muscle of of
listening to the players
of providing fixes really going through
even
veteran uh people who've worked on
on games game developers when they go
through a service
every game is different every team is
different and
it takes a lot of muscle building to
really get into the rhythm for your
teams to be able to
add to the game and so what we hope to
hear from on the technical preview side
is
again what what's working for you what's
not working for you what don't you like
remember the build is old so don't don't
treat it as if it's vinyl at all
um so as we go and go into these details
um just just remember just send us send
us your feedback
give us the details that you want to see
or improve on
um and we won't again because we're a
few
months from launch we won't necessarily
be able to fix everything for launch but
we'll start adding lists together first
thing i want to talk about from a battle
pass perspective is
is our challenges our challenge system
um
is the cornerstone it is the underlying
thing in which we go now everyone's
familiar with these we've done a little
bit different this is where you start
seeing the first rewards
you get outside of the pass so we know
right
games are a bit different today than
they were back in the day in fact
back in the day most people only had two
to three games a year that they even
looked at
today i bet you most of your steam
libraries are much larger than that
and that means players are going from
sea of thieves or they're jumping over
to age of empires
and then they're coming into halo as
well and we want to make sure that when
you sit down
you don't have to absorb an entire
battle pass to say
what are my rewards you can literally
just come in what are the challenges i
want to go play my games with my friends
and i'm going to get rewarded for it
that's pretty critical for us from a
player
first perspective and then of course
you're going to get people like me
i'm going to get sometimes get sniper
challenges now
i'm not clutch in any way shape or form
or mikwen or any other protein
i will skip the the that challenge so
i'll definitely probably swap that for
sure
and i'll want to make sure that uh i
don't have to do that because i'm not
good at it
at all so let's look at the battle pass
so we're going to buy this so what we're
going to do yeah we granted you
you're just like a real tech preview
participant we have given you some money
jared all right
good i get paid today sweet
all right sweet
got the pass we're ready to go
so as you can see oh i bought it so now
you can't see the three labels
shoot oh well yeah well you're right
what what what we're not seeing is
a smattering of objects in this pass are
free right
so even if someone doesn't want to opt
into the optional pass in the real
game there will still be a free track
and things are long yeah the main thing
you think of from from a model
that we have is every tier there's a
free item and a premium item
and that means that every single player
instead of having
uh you know most systems you have large
swaths
of of the tiers that aren't earned
unless you're premium for us we want you
to earn
every step of the way um and for the
preview
um we're only having 30 level or 20
levels sorry 20 levels in the preview
to be able to uh go after and so
uh obviously at launch we'll have much
larger we're not going to talk about
that too much but
the great thing you're seeing here is
you're seeing customization all along
the way
do you want to go to yours yeah we can
yeah josh you want to jump back over to
mine because um
i had some development sheets enabled so
i've got everything already unlocked um
actually josh switch back over to
my feed there there we go so now that we
have that context area kind of sort of
where this content is going to come from
i'm back in the
armor hall i've just kind of drilled now
into this this is what happens if i
click
in on my core right so this is we don't
need to go through all this i know folks
are probably going to see some more
gameplay we want to talk about bots in
arena as well but
you know this is where i would apply my
coatings for example some of these
coatings i'm going to earn we saw the
keystone coating as a challenge reward
for example
um so this is just a taste of kind of
what i'll be able to do
i can't wait to see how players in the
tech preview i you know i would hope a
lot of people are probably going to
easily hit tier 20 and max out
yeah um you know if not that's our hope
what are you doing you've had this long
to prepare like come on you've waited
for this to
be good go crazy but yes this is just to
give you an idea
as i lock unlock my content for the core
this is where i'm going to go in and be
able to be able to customize that
yeah and i mentioned the other day but
funny fact someone pointed out to me
that
if you want to i think for the first
time in halo game you can have no
shoulder pads which
you know hey if that's your is that's
your fancy go for it
so lots of different options here and uh
and this is like
you're not seeing things in here like
armor effects or
uh other categories that we have uh
listed here
uh for the tech preview it's really
small um
and so we tried to keep it basically the
baseline pieces
um actually let's talk about armor kit
for a little bit
yeah yeah yeah because it just i don't
think this is really so
fully supported in this build though
yeah so when we talk about um
specifically from a pillar perspective
of continuing the story
the armor kit kind of represents a bunch
of that story
and so when you see the season and when
we say story uh we mean the continuing
story of the universe
from after you when you're in campaign
as master chief
what are the rest of the spartans doing
you are a spartan and so
your story belongs here too but it's
also a place in which you can show
iconic uh characters within the halo
universe and so a kit for example
you might get um i don't know george or
a meal and that is an entire kit unto
itself and so you wanna like you
actually want to go
fly the you know do your battles on the
battlefield like george
that's where you would go uh to get that
kit
well jerry this is just the tip of the
iceberg i think there's still a ton of
fun content in here for
insiders this weekend to experiment with
unlock explore